hi everybody i'm jonathan surance and
today we're gonna have another look at a
different chest strap that you can use
now this one is called the fishing pole
trap so we'll have a quick look at it
and good luck fishing the cool thing
about the fishing pole trap here is that
what's more important is understanding
the mechanism behind it because it's the
kind of thing that can happen in a
variety of different openings here we're
gonna look at just one example but take
note of how this trap works so that
maybe you'll be able to use it in the
future so the most common way and the
fastest way to reach this in a game is
after the moves
efore e5 Knight f3 knight c6 Bishop b5
the ROI Lopes and this opening really
needs no introduction it's one of the
most popular and oldest openings and
it's seen at all different levels of
play of course black can play a six here
that's a very common move but today
we're going to look at the Berlin
defense with Knight to f6
and white will usually continue with the
move castles and he is allowing black to
play the move Knight takes e4 which is
the most common way to play but it's not
the trickiest and after Knight takes e4
white will usually be able to regain the
pond so the pawn sacrifice is only
temporary
but we're gonna look at the tricky line
Knight to g4 now this of course is
fishing for tricks here because he's
hoping after the move h3 that he can
play the move h5 and so the H pawn here
that's the hook and the bait is on g4
he's trying to tantalize white into
taking that night because there's a big
trap so white really should ignore what
black is doing and just play a simple
move like c3 and then he'll have a much
better position but if he accepts and he
takes the bait we can go ahead and take
on g4 and now white is in big trouble
because anywhere he moves the knight
let's say Knight to e1 he's gonna run
into a lot of problems on the edge file
and the fact that we have a rook on the
H file and a queen that can quickly come
to h4 spells very bad news for white and
white can play here either f3 or f4 the
only way to escape the checkmate and one
move is to try to make look so let's
play f4
now here black has to play the right
move so go ahead and think I'll give you
just a couple seconds what's the move
that black has to play in this position
I hope you were able to find it
g3 black shuts the door out and white
has absolutely nothing to do to stop the
mate
though there's only one move white can
play in this position and it's not a
move he really wants to play Queen to h5
delays mate for one move but obviously
it just throws your queen away now you
guys are the chess artists so you can
determine which way you'd want to take
the Queen here but my personal
preference is Queen takes h5 and white
can do anything he wants let's say rook
f3 and if you give me just one more move
I'll be able to take on g3 or my king
will be able to run away going to F 1 e
2 etc but it's not your turn so black
gets to drop the Queen down and it's
checkmate alright so that does it today
for the fishing pole trap hopefully you
guys were able to figure out the
mechanism of opening the H file and then
getting your Queen in there all of a
sudden and being able to seal the door
and ultimately deliver the checkmate she
got me again
if you like this video please subscribe
to our YouTube channel high-quality
stuff just like this and lots of Lulu
thank you very much